Salut à tous, cette vidéo est
sponsorisée par N26. N26 est une banque
en ligne disponible des 0 € par mois.
Vous disposez de niban français et de la
possibilité d'effectuer des paiement
sans frais partout dans le monde. Le
solde s'actualise en direct afin de
maîtriser totalement votre budget parce
que si vous ne maîtrisez pas votre
budget, c'est votre budget qui vous
maîtrisera.
N6, c'est également la possibilité
d'ouvrir ou de fermer des comptes en 5
minutes ou de créer des cartes
virtuelles permettant des achats en
ligne en toute sécurité avec évidemment
un service client disponible en français
et 7 jours sur 7 jusqu'à 23h. C'est
aussi des espaces qui sont des
sous-comptes pratiques pour diviser son
budget et mettre de côté. Ouais. Et
comme ça je pourrais aller m'abonner sur
chatc.com.
Et pourquoi vous avez bipé ? J'ai dit
chatter sur lesbouilloncube.com.
C'est là où il y a les plus grosses
salles. Recevez 30 € pour toute
ouverture de compte avec le code JDG30
jusqu'au 8 juin. Pour en bénéficier,
suivez le lien en description ou le QR
code qui s'affiche juste ici. Rentrez le
code à l'inscription puis après avoir
dépensé ou retiré 30 € sur votre compte,
vous les recrédite après 7 jours.
Parfait pour vous acheter. Une tirlire
qui hurle quand vous mettez de l'argent
dedans. Pourquoi j'ai acheté ça ?
Les pommes de terre, je les cuis puis je
les écras
aussi. J'ajoute un œuf dans mon plat et
du
sel.
Voilà. Je roule en bout d'un
léger. Je coupe des bouts carrés.
Plonger dans l'eau, ils s'en vont quand
ils
reviennent. C'est bon.
Ah, ça suffit. C'était il y a 11 ans.
[Musique]
make sense for
get so much to see so much taking the
backet you never know if you don't
go if don't go
[Musique]
now
get
all shooting
[Musique]
1 2 3
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Alors, lettre de menace, lettre de
menace, lettre de menace pizza domino.
Veuillez acheter notre pizza band [ __ ]
sinon on vous tue l'être de menace les
jeux Shrek s'il y a bien un truc qui est
ancré dans le début des années 2000
c'est bien Shrek c'est super
identifiable c'est bourré de rêve pop
culture ça parlait aux ados voilà ça
parlait aux enfants. Bref c'était le
carton et pourtant c'est à la fois très
associé au début des années 2000 et en
même temps étrangement très actuel.
Shrek, c'est quasiment les premiers
mêmes d'Internet et c'est des trucs qui
sont encore très utilisés aujourd'hui
alors que pourtant les films ont 20 ans.
Shrek, c'est un peu le moment où
l'humour absurde commence à ressembler
un petit peu à du cheat post mais un peu
trop lesque au gresque avec un fort
potentiel de partage viral he très méta
et donc très adapté à internet. Et même
au niveau des jeux vidéos, les premiers
modes qui sortent en général sur tous
les jeux modables, c'est toujours des
trucs à la con pour mettre Shrek à la
place du héros. Vous pouvez aller sur
Nexus mode, taper Shrek dans la barre de
recherche et c'est parti pour un voyage.
Hogwards Legacy, un des premiers modes,
c'était pour mettre Shrek à la place du
balai. Vous pouvez remplacer le chat de
Stray par Shrek. Vous pouvez remplacer
Payment de Genchin Impact par Shrek.
Vous pouvez remplacer toutes les
textures de Skyrim par
Shrek. Ah non, moi je fais pas ça. Moi
non, je peux
pas. B de malade. Et les jeux Shrek, ça
n'a pas commencé avec les modes, hein,
Dieu merci. Ça a commencé avec la sortie
du premier film et pour ça il faut
remonter. Attends, j'y
vais. Bon, j'imagine que beaucoup
d'entre vous considèrent que le premier
jeu Shrek, c'est celui-là, simplement
intitulé Shrek sur Xbox. Sauf que et non
parce qu'en fait, le premier jeu Shrek
est sorti en réalité le 29 mai 2001 sur
Game Boy Color, à peine 10 jours après
la sortie du film et intitulé Shrek
Fairytale Freakdown et étrangement un
jeu de combat. Le jeu commence par un
écran titre. Ah oui ouis d'accord. Ah
ouais. Waouh ! Tu sais déjà rien qu'en
voyant l'écran titre que c'est fini.
Regardez Shrek. Ah non mais il voit des
choses dans son esprit hein. Et et même
au niveau de la sélection des
personnages, regardez ça. Il y a pas une
image qui a pas l'air maudite ? Genre tu
regardes ça 7 jours après tu meurs. En
fait le jeu est considéré comme le pire
jeu Shrek jamais sorti mais je vous
avoue que je sais pas trop comment
confirmer ça quoi. C'est c'est comme
chercher la boule de merde la plus
odorante de la fausse sceptique. Alors
du coup, quelle a été l'erreur de ce jeu
de combat Shrek sur Game Boy Color ?
C'est un jeu de combat Shrek sur Game
Boy Color. Alors certes il y a des vrais
problèmes. Les contrôles sont raid, il y
a peu de personnages, c'est moche, c'est
moche, c'est vraiment très très moche.
Et en plus le comble, c'est qu'on peut
pas y jouer à deux même avec le câble
link. Vous imaginez un peu tous ces
enfants tristes de ne pas pouvoir jouer
à Shrek Fairytale Frackdown avec leurs
copains ? Non, vous les imaginez pas,
c'est parce qu'il n'existe pas.
D'ailleurs, il y a tout un tas de jeux
dont je vais pas forcément parler. C'est
tous les jeux un petit peu éducatifs
hein, vous savez, sortis sur PC comme
Shrek Gameland Activity Center, le
deuxième jeu Shrek sorti. Alors, c'est
plus un jeu de combat hein, c'est un jeu
éducatif. Bon, il y a des progrès,
mais tu tu
disons que je pense qu'il y a mieux pour
éduquer un enfant. Et ça tombe bien
parce que il y a d'autres choses dans ce
jeu hein, comme par exemple des mots
croisés ou des mots mêlés ou le petit
labyrinthe au dos des paquets de Choc
àic. Trouve, trouve trouve, trouve. Bon,
c'est vrai que c'est un peu triste que
tous les jeux proposés soient trouvables
dans un Mick parade, mais j'ai bon
espoir qu'il finisse par proposer
quelque chose de plus original.
Peut-être que ça sera dans Shrek Bowler
ou encore une fois, il a l'air mais
débile. Vous allez voir, il y a pas un
jeu Shrek où Shrek n'a pas l'air d'avoir
un petit truc en plus. Le jeu c'est un
jeu de bowllying, sauf que la boule de
bowling c'est
Shrek et c'est
tout. Alors pourquoi je vous parle de ce
jeu ? Et bien c'est pour vous dire que
Shrek c'est une licence où tous les jeux
ont été faits. Tous, sans exception. Il
y a pas un type de gameplay qui n'a pas
été fait dans un jeu Shrek.
Shrek à part peut-être les RPG
paradoxalis que c'est quasiment ce qui
semble le plus évident en fait. Alors le
truc qui s'en rapproche le plus c'est
Shrek Dragon Stale, un jeu éducatif sur
V Smile. [ __ ] alors cel il est
vraiment moche et mal branlé. Par contre
les musiques sont pas mal.
Oui. Bon ben, ok, je me suis un peu
inspiré. C'est bon. C'était un
démarcheur pour une offre d'énergie là.
Mais je l'ai foutu dehors. Comment ça tu
l'as foutu dehors ? Il est juste là.
Bonjour. Est-ce que je peux vous prendre
quelques minutes ? Ça n'est pas du
démarchage. Ah non, mais ça
suffit. Allez, allez, cassez-vous là. Ah
!
[Applaudissements]
Bonjour, est-ce que je peux vous prendre
quelques minutes ? Ça n'est pas du
démarchage.
Seb, tu ne l'as pas laissé rentrer ?
Non, enfin non, pas du tout. Je enfin
juste 2 minutes quoi parce que au début
ça avait l'air vachement intéressant. Oh
non ! Qu'est-ce que tu as fait ?
Excusez-moi. Excusez-moi ça. Pardon ?
Excusez-moi. Excusez-moi. Allô ?
Excusez-moi. Excusez-moi. Excusez-moi.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Euh
écoute, on on va capituler et collaborer
avec l'ennemi. Et si on leur obéit bien
et qu'on fait toutes leur sales
besognes, peut-être dans quelques
années, ils nous laisseront partir.
Ouais, mais ça c'est ta solution à tout.
On peut pas juste fuir ? Oui, oui, on
peut faire ça aussi. Écoute, tiens,
prends cette veste et essaie de l'agir
exactement
comme je vous offrend actuellement des
réductions importantes pour ceux qui
avant la fin du moisie 100%
renouvelable.
La
exceptionnelle d'énergie 100 %
renouvelable. Tout ça tarif très
compétitif pour votre carrière
professionnelle. Est-ce que vous avez
déjà l'envisager de comparer une autre
d'énergie avec votre votre action
environnementale
? Qu'est-ce qu'on fait du coup ? On va
aller en ville et demander à ce qui nous
débarrasse de ces gênurs. Tu veux pas
qu'on utilise des arbres à feu et qu'on
règle ça nous-même comme d'habitude ?
Bah non, on a plus le droit y paraît. Oh
! Et ainsi nos héros commencèrent à
marcher pour ne plus entendre les
vendeurs approchés. Il voulait la paix,
loin de ses offres insensées, mais l'un
d'eux semblait perdu dans ses
pensées. Ça va, ça va. Oui, oui, oui.
J'étais en train de penser au jeu Shrek.
Ça va, ça
va. Comme je disais plutôt, le premier
jeu Shrek dont la plupart des gens se
souviennent s'intitule simplement Shrek
sur Xbox sorti seulement 6 mois après.
Ça va ? Mais tu es sûr que ça va ? Parce
que tu fais vraiment une tête bizarre
là. Oui, ça va, je te dis. C'est bon,
marche. 6 mois après la sortie du film
sur Xbox et PS2, 1 an plus tard chez
nous,
on arrive dans combien de temps ? C'est
pas vrai ! Tu sais pas marcher en
silence ? Tu sais pas marcher en silence
? Remasterisé un an plus tard sous le
nom de Shrek XL sur Gamecube. Merde,
pourquoi je suis énervé comme ça ? Bon
allez, donc c'est parti pour le jeu.
Bah, c'est bizarre, il y a pas de
son. D'accord, c'est parti pour Shrek.
Le jeu se passe après le premier film et
raconte comment Shrek doit sauver sa
tendre Fiona enlevée par Merlin qui
demande contre sa libération que vous
récupérier sa boule de cristal des mains
de la reine de glace. Au niveau
gameplay, on a donc une touche pour
sauter, une touche pour frapper, une
touche pour contrôler la caméra, une
touche
pour Ah, c'est pas drôle, arrêtez de
rire et stop. Et au passage, ce bouton,
c'est pas juste là pour le fun. C'est
une vraie mécanique de gameplay. Tu peux
immobiliser tes adversaires avec tes
proutes. Tu peux maintenant enflammer
ton proute. C'est donc ça qui vous
plaît, vous les jeunes. On commence par
le premier niveau. Le petit chapeon
rouge qui veut récupérer son panier à
bonbons. [ __ ] ! Et et lui il a
vraiment encore l'air débile he ! C'est
incroyable. J'en sais quelque chose. Je
passe par ce épisode de l'amour et dans
le prê. En fait, j'ai vu ta sensibilité
et j'ai vu un homme authentique.
On va donc devoir finir chaque niveau et
au passage, si possible récupérer les
espèces de testicules volantes là qui
sont des patounes. Chaque niveau sera
donc composé d'une mini zone ouverte
avec plusieurs minijeux à réaliser pour
passer au niveau suivant qui pourront
être des des quêtes d'escort, des phases
de
plateforme, des gens à ramasser ou à
surveiller, n'importe quoi qui pourra
donc permettre de faire avancer le
scénario du jeu. scénario, hein. Wouh !
S'exclama Shrek quand il découvrit le
vieil oignon au prout suprême.
Prout proute prout prout. D'ailleurs, un
petit mot sur le gameplay puisque
évidemment beaucoup de ces minijeux vous
demanderont de courir et de sauter
partout. Le jeu vous laisse le contrôle
de la caméra avec le stick droit de la
manette et un bouton pour éloigner ou
rapprocher cette dernière. Alors ma
question, à quoi sert ce point de vue
? Professeur Grant, professeur Satler,
bienvenue à Jurassic
[Musique]
Park. Entre chaque niveau, on accède
ensuite à un genre de carte du monde qui
sert de hub général, qui est certes un
game design pas très imaginatif, mais au
moins on peut faire
[Musique]
ça. Et oui, Sébastien, tu ne rêves pas ?
bel et bien une
[ __ ] Et maintenant, je vais péter sur
les
couilles et tu ne vas rien faire car
c'est moi qui fait le montage. Bref,
nous voilà donc au niveau 2 à
Sucreville, petite ville paisible avec
ses gardes, sa bergère, son soleil ovul
entouré de
spermatozoïdes. Ces moutons et ses
habitants qui mènent une vie
tranquille. Meurs ! Meur !
Je m'énerve pour rien. Donnez-moi une
seconde, je vais aller me calmer en
pétant sur la bergère.
Trop dégueu.
Ah, ça va mieux.
Trop
dégueu. Meurs, meurs, meurs. OK, il y a
des trucs rigolos quand même. Par
contre, vous savez ce qui est pas rigolo
? Le design sonore de ce jeu, c'est
vraiment vraiment pas rigolo. Les images
que vous allez voir relatent la tragédie
qui frappe les oreilles d'un homme
devenu fou. Les événements de ce jour-là
allaient mener à la découverte de l'un
des calvires sonores les plus étranges
de l'histoire du jeu vidéo. Le niveau
des sifflé de Shrek sur Gamecube.
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Ah c'est un cauchemar. Ils ont pété les
plombes. Ça va connais dans des
histoires parler de secondes des
doubleurs de qui aussi entre l'absence
de motivation des fois. E l'ogre
arrête-toi immédiatement
le tiens prends ça vieilre puant. Bon
bref, vous avez compris l'idée les voix
insupportables. Oh mon dieu ! souffler
du dragon ou juste des erreurs de
casting. Tenez par exemple, je vous
laisse imaginer la voix de ce personnage
dans votre
tête. Ne va pas t'imaginer que nous
allons coopérer avec toi. Et puis [ __ ]
mais que je des niveaux là, on est dans
un monde magique là. [ __ ] de toi, tu
as tous les comptes de fait à ta
disposition. Tous les personnages depuis
la petite sirène jusqu'à la méchante
reine. Tu peux être dans le monde de
Alice au pays des merveilles jusque dans
le château de Cendrillon. Et qu'est-ce
qui nous donne le jeu ? Un niveau dans
les égouts. Un niveau dans les égûts. Un
niveau dans les égûts. Au niveau 3 des
ég C'est bon. Ça suffit.
Euh monsieur le narrateur ? Oui. Bah
c'est à vous là. On attend la suite de
l'histoire. Ah oui non [ __ ] pardon la
narration. Alors attends, il se passe
quoi là ? On arrive à la capitale du
royaume des jeux vidéos. La capitale du
royaume des jeux vidéos. Oui. Bon bah ça
va, c'est un compte de fait, on s'en
fout. Oui. Non ben attends, bouge
pas. Et d'un pas sûr, nos héros
arrivèrent à la capitale du royaume des
jeux vidéos. Leur mission était
capitale. Ils devaient défendre leurs
idéaux. Ouais. Bon ben, c'est pas ouf
hein. Ah ben, j'ai que quatre phrases.
Je vais pas te faire guerre épé non
plus. C'est c'est bon, laisse tomber, on
continue. On arrive à la capitale. Ça
fait longtemps que je t'ai pas venu,
mais prépare-toi à avoir des chevaliers
en armure
étincelante, des héros, de l'entraide et
surtout du bon roleplay dans une taverne
[Musique]
accueillante. C'est pas un château,
c'est
[Musique]
une maternelle. Oh ! Oh n'aurions jamais
dû venir ici. Attends, je connais
quelqu'un qui va nous expliquer ce qui
s'est passé ici.
Oh, regarde, il y a Godzina qui fait la
danse de Carton.
Laissez-moi vous raconter l'histoire de
ce royaume. Tout comme ça. Vas-y, frère,
on
[Musique]
s'arrache solaire. Qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé ? J'en peux plus. Tout se passait
bien. On avait de meilleurs graphismes,
de meilleures histoires. On évoluait
toujours plus. C'est on se disait que
tout irait bien et puis ils sont
arrivés. Qui est arrivé ? Les 2010. Les
2010 ? Oui. Ils se sont répandus
rapidement partout. Tout à cédé. Les
collabes, plus de personnalité.
Regardez-le lui là.
[Musique]
Et depuis quand est-ce que c'est arrivé
? Tout a commencé quand la princesse a
disparu. Ils ont essayé d'éliminer tous
les leur classique de jeux vidéos et
voilà où on en est. Bah nous, on a un
problème avec des démarches blanc. Vous
pouvez faire quelque chose ? Ouais. Non,
il y a que la princesse qui pourrait
faire quelque chose. La princesse ? OK,
ça fait de demander. Non, il faut la
ramener. Ouais, ouais, la ramener.
Tenez, prenez ça avec vous. C'est quoi ?
C'est un objet magique ? Non non non,
c'est c'est une Nintendo DS. La route
est super
chiante. OK. Je suivant. Shrek, Ogre et
Dranon sur Nintendo DS sorti en 2006.
Ouais, c'est parce que Ann et Dragon ça
ça fait
dran. Les jeux de mot, ça a jamais été
le point fort de cette licence. Un jeu
complètement copié sur Nintendo Dogs qui
cartonnait à ce moment-là. Et mine de
rien, c'est la première fois qu'on voit
la Nintendo DS dans un GDG. Bonjour. E
salut les copains. Oh ! Oh [ __ ] mono
les [ __ ] Dans le jeu, on doit
accompagner Shrek et Fiona et s'occuper
de leurs enfants et de ceux de LAN en
route vers la tour royale du château où
ils ont été demandés. Vous jouez donc
l'assistant de ce vieux monsieur déguisé
en bébé à qui les enfants ont été
confiés. Ah jusque là je vois aucun
problème. Et comme dans Nintends, on ne
contrôle pas vraiment les personnages.
On se contente d'utiliser les objets du
quotidien sur bébé Shrek et Bébé Hun qui
leur permettront d'apprendre des
capacités. Et le jeu nous apprend donc à
devenir des parents responsables en nous
demandant de faire des trucs comme
rotter un bébé avec sa couche sale,
laver les bébés avec la brosse du chien
ou encore agiter un truc devant eux pour
les attirer tout en faisant en sorte
bien sûr qu'il ne l'atteignent jamais.
Après ne jugez pas, j'ai été élevé
pareil, ça n'a eu aucune conséquence
psychologique sur moi. Et attrape.
Voilà, j'ai encore raté. J'ai encore
raté.
Merde, pourquoi ? Je rate toujours. Là,
typiquement pour vous montrer un
exemple, je viens de placer une poupée
sur un cube, bébé Shrek le ramasse et du
coup, je l'aurais appris à attraper
d'autres objets en hauteur. Et cette
nouvelle compétence permet de débloquer
l'accès à d'autres objets. En parallèle,
il y a aussi un système de points et de
compétences qui permettent d'acheter des
objets. Oh mais regardez, il dort. Moi,
je vais le réveiller avec un nouvel
objet que j'ai acheté. Une araignée sur
le
visage, c'est ça. Sois toujours sur tes
gardes. L'ennemi est partout. Ne fais
confiance à personne. Méfie-toi de tout
ce qui est différent. Maintenant,
venge-toi. Punis-le.
Tu as appris la violence, fils. Mon
projet d'armes vivante
[Musique]
progresse. Bon, ensuite pour le reste,
on a tout un tas d'objectifs que le jeu
nous demande de faire comme place
brocoli sur bloc B, place carotte sur
bloc C, lance pomme de terre. Allez,
prends cette pomme de terre. Voilà,
maintenant lance-la. Lance lance la
pomme de Mais non pas pas pas comme ça.
Lance la pomme. Ne la mange pas débile.
Mais [ __ ] tu es bien le fils de ton
père toi. [ __ ] il a bouffé la pomme de
terre. Oh il a chié par terre bordel. Au
passage mention spéciale à certaines
voix digitalisées. Alors il y en a des
pas mal. Nous sommes très contents de
vous voir. Cont il y en a
d'autres. On sera pas juste là.
Alors Bob, ça fait des jours passèent
depuis la capitale mais le château
n'était plus très Attends, tu fais quoi
là ? Mais j'ai pas fini. Non mais on
s'en fout des jeux portables là.
Personne n'y a joué. Allez laisse là. Je
crois que j'ai un
truc. Des jours passèrent depuis la
capitale mais le château n'était plus
très loin. Nos héros espèrent une
princesse amicale et à qui c'est
attendre. Tout vient à point.
Tu crois que c'est là ? Oui. Oui, c'est
complètement là. Merci. De rien,
connard.
[Musique]
Regarde-moi. Oh ! Oh ! [ __ ] de merde !
Attends, il y en
[Musique]
a. Oh
[ __ ] je vais essayer de tomber.
[Musique]
On va prendre de
couleurs. On fait quoi du coup ? Bah je
sais pas. On va appeler Solaire. Oh
Solaire
! Mais ça va pas de faire des trucs
comme ça. On a trouvé la princesse. Mais
maintenant on fait quoi ? Ah, c'est là
que votre quête commence. Il faut
récupérer les trois médaillons qui vous
permettront d'affaiblir la barrière
magique qui empêche de lever la
malédiction
de Qu'est-ce que vous foutez là
? Merci
chevalier. Je saigne. Vous avez dû vous
battre pour me libérer de ma
malédiction.
Oui oui oui.
Merci encore. Grâce à votre courage, le
pays va retrouver de ça. OK. Alors, on
s'en fout. Nous, on a des démarcheurs
qui ont envoyé notre grenier et on nous
a dit que vous avez des grosses
couilles. Effectivement, vous êtes bien
renseigné. Vous avez réellement des
grosses couilles ? Non, mais je veux
dire que je peux vous filer un coup de
main. Ah, super. Mais avant ça,
laissez-moi vous parler de la fin de
Shrek Xel.
Et bien donc après ce niveau dans les
égouts, on arrive au boss de la reine
des glaces. D'ailleurs, je l'ai pas dit
mais un truc intéressant à noter, c'est
que quand vous perdez contre un boss, le
jeu vous renvoie sur la World Map et
donc vous devez tout vous retaper le
niveau dans son intégralité. Et vous
savez quoi ? Je le vis très bien.
Bonjour, j'ai un colis. Alors, je suis
désolé. Par contre, je crois que je l'ai
un peu abîmé sur
Bref, donc on se bat contre la Reine des
glaces en lui pétant dessus, hein.
Évidemment, quoi d'autre ? Et cette
dernière nous explique finalement que le
vrai méchant est en réalité Merlin.
Niveau suivant avec au passage un
nouveau pouvoir débloqué, le prout
explosif à la
chaîne. Ouais, vous savez. Oui,
effectivement dans Shrek, il y a un
petit peu ce côté de Shrek, un petit peu
crado qui pète et qui rotte. Mais je
suis presque sûr qu'il y a une histoire
à côté parce que là vraiment tout le jeu
tourne autour de ça. Je dois emmener des
squelettes dans une crypte. [ __ ] je
dois kidnapper des humains dans une
usine. [ __ ] comment s'appelle le jeu
silent jamais sorti réalisé par Idéo
Kojima ? Put et puis même les les bruits
de de de ra et de paix. Oh, c'était
rigolo 10 minutes au début mais après 4
he de
jeu, c'est quoi ce bruit ? Je sais pas,
ça donne la clim qui déconne. On finit
le niveau de la montagne. Oh oui, oh,
attends. Oui, oui. Ah oui, un niveau de
chariot. Un niveau de niveau de chariot.
Enfin, un gameplay un petit peu
différent. Enfin un game. Je je vais pas
jouer. Je je vais je vais pas jouer. Je
vais pas je 100 % je vais pas jouer. Je
l'ai pas joué. Je l'ai pas joué. Je l'ai
pas joué. Je l'ai pas joué. Je l'ai pas
joué. Pourquoi je l'ai pas joué ? Je
l'ai pas joué. Jeai pas joué. J'ai pas
joué. J'ai pas joué.
[Musique]
Je vais te péter dessus comme j'ai pété
sur la reine de
classe. J'ajouterai que plus on se
rapproche de la fin du jeu he plus le
jeu est truffé de mission de merde qui
marche mal. Typiquement ce niveau-là,
vous devez ramener des squelettes dans
la crypte et pour qu'ils vous suivent,
vous devez utiliser de la musique. C'est
parti mon kiki. Ouais, le bia, le
spectacle peut commencer. C'est parti
mon kiki. Ouais. Ouais. Alors par contre
hors de question que je me tape ça tout
seul hein. Je vous laisse le son du jeu.
Donc ça ne marche pas. Pourquoi ? Parce
que je veux dire bon les squelettes sont
là, la porte de la crypte est là. Alors
pourquoi ça ne marche pas ? Juste est-ce
que est-ce que je pète dessus ? Tu es
surtout dans le jeu. Alors je p Non,
est-ce que je les tape ?
Non. Tu sais quoi ? C'est est-ce que
c'est pas la bonne crypte ? Parce que si
c'est pas la bonne de toute façon, il y
a qu'une crypte, donc c'est forcément
celle-là. Vas-y. [ __ ] la [ __ ] rentre
dans la Oh mais ta gueule toi avec ta
musique de merde. C'est plus drôle.
C'est plus drôle. Le jeu est plus drôle.
Rien n'est drôle. Pourquoi ça marche pas
? Pourquoi ça marche pas ? J'ai tout
essayé. C'est parti mon kik. lesum
squelette sur toute la carte sur fond de
musique de foire de merde. Pourquoi ça
ne marche pas ? Parce que le jeu c'est
de la merde. Parce que le jeu il te dit
ramener les squelettes à la crypte. Sauf
qu'en fait faut pas les ramener à la
crypte, il faut les ramener 15 m à côté.
La [ __ ] de ta mère. Et là ça
[Musique]
marche. Vous avez la ref hein ? Vous
avez la ref ? Vous vous l'avez la ref
hein ? Vous vous l'avez là hein ? Vous
avez la ref ? Est-ce que vous avez la
ref ? Vous avez la ref ? Et quelle
imagination ! Bien sûr, encore une fois
après le niveau du cimetière, on a donc
l'autre niveau du cimetière rempli
d'ennemis variés tels que des araignées,
des chauves-souris. OK, on est tous
d'accord là pour dire qu'ils ont
abandonné, hein ? Ils ont abandonné. On
approche donc de la fin avec des scènes
de plus en plus épiques, hein, teles que
l'apparition d'un majestueux dragon.
Je suppose que tu es venir pour la Oh
[ __ ] je joue à Shrek, je ne comprends
pas. Ah oui ! Oh ! Oh ! Ça, j'adore. Ah,
vous savez ces petites cuts scines en
début de niveau là avec un mouvement de
caméra qui passe à travers tout le
niveau pour bien te montrer comment tu
vas passer un sale moment. Oh ouais !
Ah, il manque juste une petite voix off
là-dessus là. Ouais. Ah, regarde ça. Oh
ouais, ça c'est le passage avec tous les
sauts de merde là. Oh ! Oh là là ! Ça
c'est tous les trucs chiants à
récupérer. Oh, ça va être chiant. Ah
ouais. Oh, tu vas en chier ma [ __ ]
hein ? Yes ! Elle est super
! Allez, moi je vais prendre une douche
et changer de métier. Oh la salade est
complète. Ah, c'est complet. Oh là, le
repas, le repas est terminé. Voilà, là,
il faut faire des wall jumped runner. Il
y a deux musiques superposées en même
temps dans le
[Musique]
jeu. Et la caméra se coince contre les
murs et m'empêche de voir le level de
design. Les ennemis te tirent dessus à
travers les murs, hein. Tu vois leur
projectile passer à travers les murs.
Des combats de boss de merde, une
difficulté transcendante. Alors que
c'est un [ __ ] de jeu Shrek, merde. Ah
! [ __ ] de merde de plus
jamais.
Ah bon ? Vas-y, envoie-moi ma
cinématique de Flast.
Mais alors, est-ce qu'il y a que des
jeux Shrek de merde ? Pas du tout. Je
prends Shrek 2, par exemple sur
Gamecube, un jeu qui se joue à plusieurs
où chaque joueur contrôle un personnage
différent. Le doublage de l'année là,
même que dans les films et pourquoi pas
du Clafouti avec de la bonne crème.
Fiona aussi. Un trou royal. Alors bon,
je Shrek non, mais en même temps son
doublage reste très correct. Le trajet
va être long et quand j'ai faim, je ne
suis pas de bonne humeur. Les menus sont
clair, il y a des améliorations, la
musique est sympa. Chaque personnage est
complémentaire dans le jeu. Fa peut
arrêter le temps et se bat comme dans
Matrix, comme dans les films. Petit
Biscuit est le seul avec une attaque à
distance. OK. Shrek peut porter les
objets lourds. Il y a même des minijeux
avec des musiques du
film, des
cinématiques. Attends, attendez, mais
c'est c'est Attendez, c'est c'est un bon
jeu. Pardon, j'ai ma voix qui fait ça à
chaque fois que je joue à un bon jeu et
après je me fais
dessus. Et au final, j'ai pris cet
exemple là parce que c'est le jeu qui
m'a le plus plu dans tous les jeux qu'on
a testé. Mais Shrek, c'est une licence
incroyable. C'est une licence qui a eu
tous les gameplay. Franchement, à part
Mario, est-ce que vous connaissez une
seule autre licence de jeux vidéo qui a
à la fois des jeux de combat
horizontaux, des Smash Bros, des jeux de
bowling, des jeux de cartes, des jeux
d'aventures, de plateformes, de
réflexion ou même des [ __ ] de
tamagochc. Le dernier film Shrek,
c'était il y a 15 ans et il y a encore
des actu. En 2024, il y a eu une collabe
avec Roblox. En 2023, Shrek est sur la
jaquette du jeu DreamWorks All Star Cart
Racing. Et si on n' pas parlé de tous
les jeux Shrek, il y a une raison, c'est
que même les jeux qui sont décrits par
le public, pas par moi, comme étant
plutôt mauvais, comme par exemple Shrek
Super Party, un plagia de Mario Party à
la sauce Shrek où ton personnage a la
tête du même de Spider-Man là, et bien
même ces jeux soi-disant pas ouf, moi je
les ai trouvé vraiment plutôt correctes.
Vraiment, croyez-moi quand je vous dis
que la licence Shrek, elle s'en sort
vraiment bien. Franchement, je veux
revenir sur ce que j'ai dit au début.
Les jeux Shrek, en fait, c'est pas une
fausse sceptique, c'est un puit avec de
l'eau très claire et juste quelques
merde qui flottent dedans. Et c'est bien
mal me connaître que de croire que c'est
ça qui va m'empêcher de plonger. Shrek,
maintenant ça a plus de 20 ans et ça
continue de parler aux gens. Il y a des
parcs d'attraction, des comédies
musicales, un cauchemar d'ailleurs.
[Musique]
Et surtout bien sûr un 5e film Shrek qui
arrive en 2026 et qui est évidemment
très très attendu. Tout ça pour dire
qu'il s'en est bien sorti au cinéma,
qu'il s'en est plutôt pas mal sorti en
jeux vidéo et avec le futur film qui
arrive, peut-être qui sait qu'on aura
encore des nouveaux jeux Shrek.
On va dire tu as entendu il y a la
princesse qui est revenue. Aura
peut-être des drops à gagner. Et vous
comptez les convaincre comment tous ces
gens exactement ? Mais ne vous inquiétez
pas, il faut simplement trouver les mots
justes. Un petit zess de conviction, un
soupçon d'espigglerie et un grand
sourire. C'est tout ce qu'il faut pour
convaincre tout le monde. Ah, il y a du
soleil. Trop
longtemps, une trop grande liberté a été
accordée. Descadence et perversion ont
envahi notre monde de fantaisie.
Ensemble, avec votre aide, je mettrai un
terme à la dégénérescence de notre
société. Soyez assurés que ma
détermination n'a jamais été aussi
grande. C'est un discours.
Pour garantir la
sécurité et la continuité de la
cohérence scénaristique de notre
monde, notre royaume sera bientôt
réorganisé pour une société fondée sur
l'ordre.
et la sécurité.
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Je vous envoie mon cœur.
Et ben voilà, tout est redevenu normal.
L'ordre est rétabli, les démarcheurs
blancs sont partis et comme on dit dans
les comptes de fé tout est bien qui
finit bien. Mais comment ça ça finit
bien ? Mais tu vois bien que la
princesse est une fashion victime.
Ouais. Tu as remarqué toi aussi tu as vu
comme cette petite capuche lui allait
super bien ? Non mais il y a pas photo,
je veux dire c'est c'est une naturel.
Oui, son discours est passé crème. Tu as
vu toute la presse a adoré tu sais enfin
ce qu'il en reste et c'est littéralement
le discours de mus au chocolat Sem. Oui,
tout le monde aime les mus au chocolat.
[Musique]
Ils mangèrent ensemble une délicieuse
mus au chocolat car il n'y avait rien de
meilleur que la muce au chocolat.
[Musique]
She was looking kind of dumb with a
finger and the thumb in a
shape. Well, the coming and I don't stop
coming. Fed to the rules and I hit the
grun didn't make sense not to leave for
fun. Bra gets m but your head gets done.
So much you do so much to see so much
wrong with taking the back streets. You
never know if you don't go. You never
shine if you don't go. Hey
now get your
game
now
[Musique]
get all that
leaders only
shooting break M.